hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast from genomics to
precision medicine uncovering and
manipulating the genetic circuits
underlying common disease my name is
Dean fan on lab roots and I'll be your
moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab roots the leading scientific social
networking website and provider virtual
events and webinars advancing scientific
collaboration and learning we'd also
like to acknowledge the CAF group for
help with programming and promotion of
the event before we start there a few
instructions want to hear from you
during this interactive broadcast so
please ask questions or leave us a
comment answers are welcome to you can
do this by hitting the green Q&A button
at the lower left of the presentation
window and typing in your comments and
questions we'll get we'll try to get to
as many as we can and will follow up
with you if we don't have time for
everything today if you want a better
look you can enlarge this wide window by
clicking on the screen icon at the lower
right-hand corner of the slide window if
you can't hear or see this presentation
properly let us know by clicking on the
support button at the top right or use
the Q&A button will make sure to resolve
any issues this is an educational
webinar and this offers free continuing
education credits after the webinar is
over please click on the c/e button
located at the bottom left hand corner
of your web page and follow the process
to obtain your credits now let's get
right to today's presenter we're proud
to welcome dr. Manila Skelos dr. kelas
is a professor of comput computer
science at MIT where he directs the MIT
computational biology group he has
helped direct several large-scale
genomics projects including the NIH
roadmap epigenomics project the
comparative analysis of 29 mammals the
Encyclopedia of DNA elements for the
encode project and the genotype tissue
expression project the planner for this
event has stated no relevant financial
relationships however dr. Kevin Davies
didn't disclose that he is a scientific
advisory board member for the pathway
genomics and is on the speaker
for Harry Walker ink and that neither
constitutes a conflict of interest
please note that dr. Keller's has
indicated that he has no relevant
financial relationships relative to this
topic I will now turn it over to dr.
Kellis for his presentation not yet okay
great when I see myself monster hello
thank you everyone for coming today i'll
talk to you about how we can actually
translate genomic knowledge into
personalized medicine and specifically
how we can exploit regulatory genomics
and epigenomics focusing on non-coding
disease regions so what you can see is
that precision medicine has really taken
off in the private view of across both
industry academia and the government and
the challenge is to actually deliver on
the promise of genetics so what is that
promise of genetics the promise of
genetics is bad that by carrying out a
genome-wide Association study by
basically looking at every snip position
on the x-axis across the 23 chromosomes
and then measuring for every one of
those genetic regions what is its
association with a particular trade of
interest that we can uncover genetic
regions that have a very strong very
statistically significant association
using these very simple types first
otisco tests and out of those regions we
should be able to discover new potential
target genes potentially new
therapeutics understanding mechanisms
and eventually enabling personalized
medicine but this has been a very big
challenge and there's been a lot of
anticipated challenges in understanding
the mechanism underlying human disease
but perhaps the most surprising
challenge at least in the public's view
is that the
majority of these disease regions do not
affect genes directly they do not affect
the proteins directly what they do
instead is that they alter the
regulation of these genes so when you
open up the hood under these regions and
you expand them out what do you see you
see that there are sometimes hundreds of
genetic variants but none of them is in
fact altering a protein what they do
instead is that they sit either in
intergenic or intronic regions in the
non-coding genome and the mechanism
through which they act is actually very
difficult to elucidate specifically for
non-coding regions why is that well the
first reason is that there's a very
large number of genetic variants all of
which are Co inherited you can see here
the relationship the relationship
structure of many of these variant which
are in fact simply indistinguishable
from each other in terms of their
association with disease and that makes
it very difficult to find out which of
these genetic variants is actually
driving the disease which of these
related parent is actually causal and it
also makes it very difficult to identify
what cell type the genetic variants
acting because frankly they don't affect
the genes and therefore we can't simply
utilize an expression to figure out
where they act and of course even the
target gene through which they act is
actually not known so that makes it very
difficult to identify the mechanism
through which genetic variants are
acting and NIH foresaw this and launched
a large number of initiatives for
actually dissecting the function of the
non-coding genome so the remedy that was
proposed was to systematically annotate
the non-folding genome and projects such
as the encode project Encyclopedia of
DNA elements the epigenomics roadmap
project from the NIH Common Fund or the
blueprint project from the European
Union have actually sought to
systematically annotate this non-coding
genome and to do so across a very large
number of different
cell types both in adults as well as in
earlier stages of life and even
development so the goals now starts
interpreting this information to link
enhancers and their regulators through
the targeting traffic control and to
develop new methods for utilizing that
information and the deliverables are six
fold so number one we want to figure out
what are the cell types through which
these genetic variants manifest
themselves where do they act number two
what are the genes that they control and
what are the genes whose expression is
altered between risk and non risk
individuals number three what are the
specific nucleotide mutations that are
causal number four what are the upstream
regulators who's binding is disrupted
number five what are the relevant
pathways through which these disease
variants act and number six what are the
intermediate cellular and organismal
phenotypes on the way to the disease and
that's what I'm going to try to address
today so first we're going to talk about
number one how do we actually
characterize the external make landscape
number two how do we use that to
identify disease relevant issues and
regulators number three had we combine
genetic variation and a genetic
variation in the context of disease and
number four have we uncover the
mechanisms underlying disease the
circuitry underlying disease and how do
we actually manipulate these mechanisms
so let's dive right in so how do we
actually characterize the epigenomic
landscape so the first thing we're going
to do is map non-coding elements uncover
cellular circuitry and then link genetic
variants or single nucleotide
polymorphisms to the enhancers they lie
within the target genes that control the
regulators that control them and the
cell types in which they act this is
very much following the path that was
laid out by this roadmap epigenomics
consortium paper so this was published
in Nature
in February about a year ago and this
paper basically presented the first
reference map of a very large number of
human primary tissues himself and this
was a collaboration through many
different labs across the United States
of the world and a wonderful team of
individuals working closely together
over many many years so what are we
doing this project we basically said
let's now characterize the epigenome of
a large number of adult and fetal
tissues as well as embryonic stem cells
iPS cells and IPS derived cells and for
each of those we mark three types of
modifications first we map the
accessibility of the DNA itself in other
words can a regulator actually bind a
particular piece of DNA number two we
looked at DNA methylation so cpg
dinucleotides can actually undergo
epigenetic modifications which can alter
the function of a particular genomic
region by modifying the sea in a cpg
dinucleotides in both strands directly
and then the third type of modification
is actually histone modifications and
these modifications that happen at the
tails of these histone proteins that DNA
is wrapped around so there's about a 157
147 nucleotide plus about a 50
nucleotide linker so you can think of
them as 200 base perchance along the
genome that can be modified in
particular in a very large number of
ways so we mapped five modifications
systematically across the entire genome
and a subset of additional modifications
in more than 90 different cell types and
many many more modifications in a small
number of cell types as well as DNA
accessibility DNA methylation and what
you can think of as a little bit of the
output of epigenetic information which
is the RNA expression levels of the
corresponding genes so what do we get
with that information well here's the
view for one
of the richest cell types so this is I
am r95 lung fiberglass and what you can
see is that the different modifications
are very highly correlated with each
other so you can see here that along
with RNA expression there's a large
number of modifications that actually
mark transcribed regions regions that
are made into RNA then there's a whole
set of modifications that mark promoter
regions so these are at the beginnings
of jeans and they sort of mark a little
bit of where the gene starts this is the
stop sign right before you know the gene
takes off that's where you know
polymerase makes its final decision and
then you see these marks that are
predominantly found in these digital
regulatory elements known as enhancer
regions so we were able to summarize all
of that information with these highly
correlated marks into a small number of
distinct chromatin states and we're even
coloring those in different colors that
correspond to the underlying functions
of these regions and in this total focus
a lot on these enhancer regions but we
annotate the entire to the genome in
enhancers the color of approximately one
percent of the genome in each cell type
promoters that cover another one percent
transcribed regions that cover
approximately ten to fifteen percent and
then repress regions that cover another
few percentages as well as these
unannotated white regions that you see
here that simply don't show any of these
modification marks so we basically can
summarize all of that information in
each of the cell types going from dozens
of tracks in some of the cell types into
a single track that basically tells you
using this very simple nomenclature what
is the underlying function of that piece
of chromatin so now because we can
actually summarize that very rich
information a single track we can
actually look at that same track in a
very large number of cell types so we've
done exactly that looking at more than a
hundred different human cell types and
this is what you see here so across 127
cells and tissues from each of these
samples we're able to now man these
chromatin states and see at a glance how
this particular gene which I showed you
as being repressed in this previous
slide is in fact repressed in most of
the cell types except for a handful of
cell types where it's in to escape
expression escape repression and then
you can see the promoter turning on here
a large number of enhancer elements
turning on here and then transcription
going in this particular case from the
right to the left of the slide you see
other genes that are turning on in a
subset of cell types and you can also
see other genes that are constitutively
on the other thing you'll notice is that
the promoters of these genes seem to be
on even when the genes are not being
actively transcribed so that actually
suggest that these regions are actually
open pretty constitutively across
different cell types but in other
regions you see these enhancers that are
turning on and off very dynamically and
different sets of enhancers turning on a
different cell types so we can actually
utilize this information to start
learning something about the regulation
of these cells how but basically taking
all enhancer elements across the genome
lining them up side by side across 2.3
million of these elements and then
asking how do they relate to each other
so we basically did exactly that so we
looked at 2.3 million open chromatin
regions that show these enhancer histone
modification marked and then we look at
the vector of activity across 127 cell
types and we cluster them together into
blocks of coordinated activity and now
it's really exciting is that if you look
at the genes underlying these blogs they
actually play roles that make a lot of
sense based on the tissues in which they
are active so the enhancements that are
active in in t-cells and b-cells play
immune roles the enhancers that are
active in embryonic stem cells make
developmental roles the enhancers active
in the brain played learning and memory
roles and so on and so forth
we can also utilize that information to
start looking for sequence patterns or
regulatory motifs that are found within
these regions and correspond to the
regulators that likely control these
elements and you can also utilize the
activity patterns of these regions
across different cell types in order to
link together enhancers to the genes
that the control through the coordinate
activity of the modules of genes that we
just discovered here and the modules of
gene expression which can be learned
exactly the same way so what that
results in is a systematic a map that
now allows us to grow in any region of
association and start mapping what are
all of the genetic elements that are
altered in these regions and these are
individual single nucleotide
polymorphisms what are the enhancers in
which they fall what cell types are
these enhancers active in what are the
genes that each of these enhancers is
likely controlling and who are the
regulators that control each of these
elements so we can go basically from a
unannotated non-coding region that
contains no protein alterations into a
very complex circuit that basically
tells you who are the likely target
genes who are the likely driver snips
what are the enhancers that are altered
or the cell types in which the function
and who are the regulators upstream of
that so I see a couple of questions but
I guess I'll take them at the end and
believe that some of them are already
answered so the so we have actually
taken all of that information and we've
put it into a database we call this
database hot leg for haplotype
regulation so if you just google app leg
you'll be able to find it or you can
simply type compiled mit.edu / appareil
and this this was originally published
in 2011 and it was updated just a couple
of months ago
in the database issue of the na are so
for every genetic variant this tool
allows you to look at all of the other
genetic variants that are co inherited
with it and for each of them allow you
to mine all of these extremely rich
information about enhancer activity
promoter activity DNA accessibility
which proteins are actually bound what
are the motifs that are disrupted or
altered by these very specific
alterations and what are the genes that
are downstream of that so we can now
share all of that information with the
world for people to make insights on any
genetic regions that they care about but
we also want to utilize that information
to gain insights into human disease so
I'm going to talk in the remainder of
the talk about how we can actually
utilize this information of mapping
these non-coding elements and uncovering
these circuits to actually gain insight
in the tissues and the regulators that
control human disease and that that's
the next session section so this is
joint work with Luke Ward and Jason
Earth's with a professor at UCLA so
we're now going to utilize these
epigenetic maps to predict what are the
tissues in which these genetic variants
are likely to act so how do we do that
we basically start in every for every
trait in the gos catalog with all of the
genetic variants that are associated
with a trade we basically look at every
region of association and within these
regions of association at the specific
snips that are the most associated with
the disease so we can now do that not
just for one trade but for every trade
and we can basically get different
genomic intervals associated with
different trades in this particular tune
and on top of that we can now overlay
the epigenomic annotations so for
example all of these regions
there are active in stem cells and we
can basically ask well what is the cell
type that is the most enrich here and
you can see that they overlap over and
over again genetic variants that are
associated with height so that allows us
to now say well let's put a check mark
here in terms of the you know genetic
variants associated with height are
quite likely to act in stem cells and we
can do the same thing with immune cells
and you know put a checkbox here for
specific immune disorders we can do the
same thing for you know hard enhancers
the same thing for liver enhancers and
that actually gives us a picture of what
are the cell types in which every
genetic trait might act in a completely
unbiased way and what that leads to is
this map here which is actually real
data that summarizes a lot of
information that i painted on the
previous slide you can see here high is
associated with embryonic stem cell
activity in the unit rate is associated
are associated with a t-cell and v
selectivity the genetic variants that
are associated with blood pressure for
example appear to act in you know
specifically one cell type which is the
left ventricle and that makes a lot of
sense that's that's where the blood
pressure gets built up prior to being
pumped in the rest of the body if you
look at the genetic variants associated
with cholesterol you can basically trace
them to you know liver enhancers and if
you look here at the fasting glucose
related trades you can actually trace
them to pancreatic islets which again
makes a lot of sense in terms of insulin
secretion if you look at inflammatory
bowel disease you see this very strong
enrichment for immune cell types but
also follow all these genetic cell types
and then lastly there are some surprises
if you look at Alzheimer's disease in
the second-to-last rind and you trace it
out you don't actually see an enrichment
in these brain tissues you know where
one would have expected but instead you
see this very strong
judgment in monocytes so these are cd14
+ cells so we partnered up with our
collaborator liquids I over at the
picker Institute and for student Lystra
neska and my student undress planning
and what we basically did is that we
took this initial hint and we carried
out experiments both in mice and in
humans to see what is really this immune
component of Alzheimer's disease and
what we found is that there are two
types of changes that are happening
during progression of Alzheimer's
there's certainly repression of these
neuronal neuronal genes both at the RNA
level at the promoter level and at the
enhancer level but you also see this
activation of these immune regions and
what's really interesting is that the
repression actually happens later during
the disease progression then the
activation of the immune cells so that
actually suggests that perhaps the
neuronal component is in fact downstream
of the immune component or more bluntly
that this is not simply a case of
neuronal degeneration leading to
inflammation and turning all of these
immune genes but it might actually be
the way the other way around so the
prediction is that immune cell this
regulation is in fact a causal component
of the disease because of the temporal
differences between immune activation
that happens earlier than your own or
repression as well as because of the
enrichment of these genetic variants
that are associated with Alzheimer's
disease which happens specifically in
the cd14 primary cells which are markers
of both microglial cells that are the
resin immune cells of the adult brain as
well as macrophages that infiltrate the
brain during your degeneration so from
this very simple view we can already
gained a lot of insight into the
teachers and the regulators
underline specific disorders but what's
really interesting here is that we can
actually utilize this epigenomic
information to predict additional
genetic regions that are associated with
disease so as I showed in my first slide
genetic variants associated with human
disease very often are very very
significant you know they passed this
genome-wide significance threshold of 5
times 10 to the minus 8 but there's a
large number of genetic variants that
are modestly associated with disease and
do not reach genome-wide significance
with current cohort sizes so we
basically asked Kenley actually
characterize sub threshold variants that
are associated with a specific disorder
using the information that we can learn
from the genome-wide significant
variance and we basically learned a
large number of these signatures such as
where are these regions active where are
they not active you know where are they
differentially methylated how are they
conserved across different species and
so on and so forth in order to develop a
predictor that can now tell us well in
this twilight zone of sub threshold
variants which of those are actually
more likely to be biologically
meaningful and we were able to actually
experimentally validate a large number
of those using Lucifer's assays as well
as chromatin interactions and we were
also able to validate them using human
genetic evidence which is much stronger
for the sub-threshold variants that
we're prioritizing as well as Mouse
evidence by specifically disrupting
these genes in minds again leading to a
contractility phenotype in this
particular case much more frequently for
those genetic parents that we prioritize
and we even carried out specific
disruptions using morpholino technology
in zebrafish and we found indeed a
change in the repolarization duration
for those predicted target genes so
discovering these regions using only
genome-wide Association study
would have actually require 60,000 we
would have required 60 140,000 dividuals
but we can actually do that with only a
much smaller number of individuals we
can also combine genetic and epigenetic
information together so up until now I
told you about how we can use epigenomic
annotations in reference cell types but
we can actually see how these epigenetic
information is actually changing across
different individuals in the context of
disease so we can actually map multiple
different cell types and observe
methylation changes enhancer changes and
so on and so forth across each of these
tissues to basically understand how are
these leading to gene expression changes
and ultimately intermediate phenotypes
that lead to disease and this is
actually very hard because we actually
have to account for potential feedback
from the environment or the disease
state itself so in collaboration with
Phil the jager and David Bennett we
basically looked at methylation profiles
across a large number of Alzheimer's
patients and controls and for each of
them we observe their genome their epi
genome using methylation profiling as
well as their phenotype using a rich set
of phenotypes followed over more than 10
years and what we find is that a very
large number of genetic variants
influence the methylation profile across
the genome so 50,000 different regions
are actually associated with genetic
changes that lead to epigenetic
differences between these individuals
and what's really interesting is that
these changes actually focus on these
enhancer regions these distal regulatory
regions so they happen predominantly in
these intermediate methylation regions
not at the most extremes of DNA
methylation and these intermediate
regions are the most enriched in
enhancers which are by far the most
intermediately methylated regions we can
also look at the overall variability
across individuals and what we find is
that enhancers are by far the most
valuable and promoters are by far the
least variable differing by an order of
magnitude in their variability and
lastly promoters are actually depleted
in genotype driven variation where's
enhancers are actually enriched in this
genotype based variation and lastly
enhancers are actually the most
predictive in their ability to classify
whether an individual is an Alzheimer's
case or control in our data set whereas
promoters are actually much less
informative and genetic information
alone is much much less informative so
that allows us to now predict genetic
regions that are predictive of
Alzheimer's disease and these regions
are indeed quite enriched in the genetic
variants that are associated with
Alzheimer's disease so if you rank all
of the genetic all of the methylation
probes based on their association with
Alzheimer's the strongest enrichment for
genetic association with Alzheimer's is
found at the very top of the rank list
and correcting for the effect of genetic
variants on methylation actually reduces
our ability to predict Alzheimer's
disease suggesting that in fact
methylation is a causal component or
late on the way to disease we can also
do this in the context of multiple
phenotypes and what we're finding is
that different genomic intervals are in
fact associated with different subsets
of Alzheimer's different phenotypes and
that these subsets are in fact playing
very different roles in the biology of
Alzheimer's disease so different subsets
of functional pathways are associated
with different phenotypic signatures of
Alzheimer's and these actually manifest
themselves in specific cell types so
depending on the specific signature of
Alzheimer's disease between redic
plaques neurofibrillary
Tango's cognitive decline the genetic
variation probes that are associated
with differences in those in either
promoters or enhancer regions are in
fact active in very specific cell types
lastly we can actually put all of that
information together and discover and
manipulate the specific mechanisms
underlying human disease so let's go
through those six steps that I promised
in my very first slide so what we would
like to know is starting from a genetic
region that is associated with disease
which contains a large number of highly
Co inherited genetic variants can we
actually identify what are the tissues
and cell types in which it acts what are
the target genes that is control what
are the causal nucleotides that are
driving this association who are the
upstream regulators that are binding to
these nucleotides differentially between
risk and non risk individuals and lastly
what the cellular and the organism or
phenotypes that result from these
alterations and we applied all this in
the context of obesity in the strongest
genetic region associated with obesity
and this is work that we did jointly
with Melina claussen sir who's now a
professor at Harvard Medical School so
this was published recently in the New
England Journal of Medicine this past
August so I don't need to convince you
how important obesity is it costs more
than 200 billion dollars a year in the
US alone and it affects 500 million
people worldwide the strongest genetic
association with obesity was discovered
in this FTO region more than 70 years
ago and this region is quite remarkable
because the genetic variants spanned a
total of forty thousand nucleotides and
there are 89 common variants that are
quite strongly associated with the
disease making it very difficult to
identify what the causal variant is and
there's been a large amount of previous
work associated with these locals but
that has resulted in very conflicting
genes comply
in tissues and the focus has actually
being previously on brain and an
appetite but we basically said if they
can unbiased view and see what we can
learn about this region so what we're
finding is going through these six steps
number one we find that the strongest
epigenetic signal is actually found in
the cells that are not acting in the
brain remarkably but instead are
deciding between this developmental
lineage of why adipocytes which store
lipid and have this you know very very
big juicy you know energy store and
these brown adipocytes that are actually
very rich in mitochondria and burn
energy dissipated energy is heat and
this intermediate cell type known as
beige or bright idea besides that are
sharing a developmental faith with the
wide adipocyte lineage but share a lot
of their properties with the brown
adipocytes the second step that we
wanted to go through is identify the
target genes and you can see here how
this genetic locus is extremely
localized right on top of this fto gene
but in fact it sits within a very large
region of three-dimensional folding of
the chromosome where a large number of
other genes might actually be potential
targets and what we're finding is that
only two of these genes actually show
genetic differences between homozygous
risk individuals and homozygous
non-resistant dividuals for this at your
lotus and these two genes are ir x 3 and
ir x 5 that are sitting 500,000
nucleotides and 1.2 million it resides
away from this genetic region suggesting
that he acts at very very large
distances with a very strong genetic
effect the third step was to identify
what is the causal variant and here we
actually use
comparative genomics of a large number
of species to identify modules of
regulatory motifs that are highly
conserved across the species but
disrupted in the individuals that carry
the specific genetic mutation and in
this particular case is predicted one of
three possible regulators as the target
of this disruption and a single
nucleotide variant rs14 to 1085 which
changes at T in this 80 rich motif into
a sea which abolish is the binding
according to our models indeed we found
that if you go in perturb both the
transacting regulator and the regulator
motif in a conditional analysis between
the cyst and the trans you find that you
actually require the intact regulator
and the impact motif in order to get
successful repression but disrupting
either of them leads to depression both
at the enhancer level as well as the
gene expression level for both ir x3 and
ir x5 so what that tells us is that we
now have a complete circuitry we started
with these regional association and we
were able to narrow down the tissue the
target genes the causal loop low tide
and the option regulator but I still
haven't told you about how this actually
leads to obesity and that's where we
utilize these target genes are exterior
x5 in order to gain more insights about
how it actually functions what we found
is that genes with mitochondrial
functions were negatively correlated
with both ir x 3 and ir x five words
genes involved in lipid metabolism were
positively correlated with both genes
and indeed this difference which exists
to shift from energy dissipation to
energy storage in the risk individuals
this defense was reflected at the
cellular of phenotypes of those
individuals the risk individuals had
much lower DNA content for the
mitochondria suggesting much less much
longer by
genesis and they also had much larger
adipocytes suggesting an accumulation of
lipids when we found therefore is that
there's this hello sorry I'm in the
middle of a webinar I thought he was the
webinar calling I can't talk right now
sorry sorry guys I thought it was a call
from the organizers I'm almost wrapped
up here so here we here we have the
model for the t-shirt onymous role of
adipocyte metabolism mean obesity and
the beauty of having the circuitry is
that we can actually start manipulating
it we can actually reverse this effects
and switch between lean and of these
phenotypes by actually intervening at
each one of these noms if you wish so we
can control the target genes we can
control the genetic variant itself and
we can control the option regulator and
in every one of these cases we see that
we can actually switch between lean and
obese phenotypes exactly as you would
predict based on knock down or
overexpression of either of these genes
or based on editing of that single
nucleotide and now when we talk about
precision medicine imagine that out of
the 3.2 billion nucleotides in the human
genome I could tell you that there's a
single nucleotide who's editing from the
sea risk allele to the team protective
allele would actually reverse the
cellular signatures of obesity and
indeed we went in and we edited you know
this nucleotide from T to see and from C
back to team showing that we could
actually lead to the repression of
eraklyon or x5 and the repression again
upon editing with chris perkins 9 we can
also reverse the loss of thermogenesis
in the risk individuals so you can see
here that the risk individuals are
unable to turn on
this process of heat dissipation upon
stimulation but as soon as you read it
at single nucleotide you actually see a
sevenfold increase in the process of
thermogenesis both basal as well as
stimulated suggesting that we can in
fact find the causal nucleotide at the
cellular level altering the expression
of either I rx-3 or I are X 5 in either
risk or non risk individuals can
actually flip between the risk and non
risk phenotypes suggesting that again
these are the causal driver genes and
lastly going into mice we can actually
repress this I rx3 gene and what we find
is that it actually leads to a fifty
percent loss in body weight for this
individuals at fifty percent loss in fat
mass ratio a complete resistance to body
weight gain in a high-fat diet for these
minds and no change in appetite no
change in exercise and instead what you
see is increased energy utilization when
these mice are awake but also when these
mice are sleeping so even in their sleep
these mice are actually burning more
energy through this process of
thermogenesis so we can now directly
manipulate the disease signatures by
understanding how this genetic variants
are acting on the you know specific
nucleotide at the altar on the target
genes that the altar and on the
ultimately cellular phenotypes that we
can actually now serve a neatly and the
FTO variant was number 14 in a very long
list of dramatically significant
genome-wide significant non-coding
variant and we need now new technologies
for going through those systematically
and we are engaging several
computational and experimental
collaborations for systematically
evaluating the effects of non-coding
variants across a large number of
different lineages and
it's carrying out cellular assays in
high-throughput ways in order to
understand how we can actually detect
these regions so what I told you about
is how we can number one utilize
regulatory genomics and epigenomics to
characterize the genomic landscape mad
non-coding elements and cover their
circuitry and Link non-coding variants
to their enhancers their target genes
the regulators and the cell types in
which they act number two how we can
identify the disease relevant issues and
regulators which gave us a lot of
insights and Alzheimer's disease and
which allowed us to discovering new
heart regularization jeans with cardiac
function below genome-wide significance
and we can actually combine genetic and
epigenetic information together to
discover the central of enhancers and to
identify low sign that are important in
Alzheimer's disease we can now take
these low side under standard circuitry
and manipulate their circuitry
systematically in order to understand
disease mechanism this has been an
amazing collaboration with a large
number of individuals for the roadmap
epigenomics project the co first altars
were uncle kindaichi watermelon land and
Jason Ernst so the cardiac sub-threshold
low side is collaboration with cinching
wrong and Lori Boyer for the Alzheimer's
disease genetics and epigenetics this is
a collaboration with Philly Hagar and
David Bennett for Alzheimer's disease in
mouse this collaboration illiquid ties
lab and for the mechanistic dissection
of fto this is worth that was initiated
and led by Molina Klaus answer for
several years and I did not have too
much time to talk about those so I'll
stop there i'll be very happy to take
any questions and i see a few of these
questions already but I'm time to open
the floor so I can read off the
questions so I see a question by Kevin
Davies who is basically asking how would
you like to see if genomic analysis
incorporated into the precision medicine
initiative this is a fantastic question
so the precision medicine initiative as
you all know seeks to establish a
national cohort of a million
with very rich phenotypes that will now
participate in a very open way in a
ricola berated way in a systematic
linking between genetic differences and
phenotype I agree with Kevin that
mapping the molecular phenotypes of
these individuals is extremely important
and that's something that can be done in
a large number of blood cell types
without too much hassle by actually
simply you know taking that blood sample
and separating into a large number of
different cell types which will allow
some cover a lot of the immune processes
underlying disease the moment you want
to go to additional cell types that are
diseased relevant such as the brain
liver the hard part credit islet it
becomes much more challenging to get
volunteers to donate you know pieces of
their body effectively but these can be
overcome using reference code words I
did not have time to talk about that but
we're very involved in the genome
genotype each expression project or
gtechs which actually has mapped more
than a nickel which is actually mapping
more than a thousand individuals and
more than 40 different tissues across
these individuals in some cases and this
is post-mortem samples so it poses
certain challenges associated with that
but one of the things that we're doing
there is in addition to RNA variation in
gene expression patterns we're looking
at a pija netic differences between
these individuals in order to build a
reference map for how genetic
differences mapped of genetic
differences and that's something that
can be leveraged by this national cohort
william proc Lanier is asking what
effect will this approach have on
pharmacogenomic diagnostic panel
development this is a great question so
a lot of what I talked about is how
differences in our genome is in fact our
artifact leading to differences in our
predisposition to disease but the same
genetic variants or different genetic
variant scattered across our genome are
also leading to differences in how we
respond to treatment and in fact there
are dozens of drugs
in the market right now that have
genetic indications in them that allow
individuals to design of the doe's of
treatment or decide on whether to use a
drug or not based on their genetic
makeup and I think we're going to see a
lot more of that and sometimes by
actually mapping which genetic variants
are leading to differences in the
response to particular drug we can
actually understand better how the drug
itself is acting and maybe even get more
insight into the pathways underlying
specific disorders for which the
standard of care with developed a long
time ago without much knowledge of the
underlying molecular effect of these
particular interventions and we can
actually start systematically
understanding those effects right now
unless the cs Subhan Allah is asking do
you know any example of the clinical
trials using enhancer modifiers in human
if yes was it successful so in cancer
there's a lot of interest in modifying
the epigenome directly so a lot of
histone deacetylase inhibitors or H DAC
inhibitors are in fact commonly utilized
in the context of cancer as a way to
alter the circuitry of these cancer
cells which are in fact dis regulating
their own genome and epigenome in order
to evade you know the immune system in
order to evade apoptosis in order to
proliferate and so on and so forth so
epigenetic treatment is very much at the
forefront of cancer research right now
in terms of being able to number one
shock the system in order to you know
perhaps uncocks reverse and undo some of
the reprogramming that may have actually
led to the cancer stake in the first
place the much more subtle epigenomic
reprogramming of specific cancer types
in order to reverse in a much more
precise way the effects of the disease
is something that is not currently
done but it's something that should be
very much in the in the horizon how to
use the genomic information in possible
synergistic action of investigating
drugs so this is going a step beyond
pharmacogenomics to basically look at
the combination of multiple drugs
together and that's again a natural
extension but something something that
has not yet been done and how r enhancer
is linked with regulatory genes I
covered that at the beginning part of
the way that we link enhancers to their
target genes is through the
three-dimensional folding of the genome
through the genetic interactions between
genetic variants of the enhancer and the
expression of the gene to control as
well as through the coordinated activity
of the enhancer region and their target
genes so I don't see any more questions
you know feel free to type them up but
it's been a real pleasure seeing so many
of you attend and I wait another couple
of minutes to see if there's any more
questions and if not you know I'll turn
it over to the tears well thank you for
an excellent excellent presentation and
thank you for taking all the questions
those are really great I just wanted to
ask you once more if you have any final
comments for the audience before we go
coupling so um yeah so I mean I think
the promise to the audience is basically
very much a call for action so I think
there's a lot of interest out there from
academia from industry from the
government in genomics right now I think
we need a lot more basic education
genomics I think we need a lot more
involvement
and I think the main thing that we need
that can really reverse the course of
genomics is patient advocacy it's
basically for people to take a whole of
their own genetic information and to to
basically really reverse the tide in
openness and sharing of information a
lot of the results that I mentioned a
lot of the successes that the field has
had have relied upon a very broad
sharing of genetic epigenetic and
functional information there's a lot of
projects that are mapping these
reference data fit but at the same time
combining all of these with genetic
information exposing a lot of new
challenges in terms of privacy in terms
of ethics in terms of non-discrimination
and I think you know what we need is
really the people of the patients the
you know advocacy groups to come
together and to sort of help share
information help disseminate information
help build these resources and help put
all of this information to the hands of
researchers in industry and academia in
the government so very much different
versions of the three different branches
here coming together and sort of
collaborating broadly and I think you
know patients are going to get the
center of all of this so anyway thank
you so much guys for for listening
there's an awesome presentation by
Nathan in about eight minutes so stay
tuned looking for it all right I see
another Q&A lighting up let me see if
there's one more question all right
fortunately we're running out of time so
maybe dr. Keller's can respond to that
last question individually just to wrap
up today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through August of 2016
you will receive an email from us
alerting you when it's available on
demand and posted on lab routes comm
please feel free to forward this to any
of your colleagues who weren't able to
join in today and thank you again for
logging in and participating in today's
webcast we hope to see you again soon
bye bye
you